هناك ثلاثة أنواع من العدوى جاهزة للتسبب في إحداث ضرر
بصحتك، حيث
نرى أنماطًا متغيرة من الأشخاص الذين
يعودون إلى المدارس،
ويتواجدون في منازلهم على مقربة من بعضهم
البعض، وهذا عادة ما يبدأ
موسم فيروسات الجهاز التنفسي، مثل الأنفلونزا RSV
وكوفيد-19.  من المتوقع أن ينتشر فيروس كوفيد-19
في الولايات المتحدة خلال الأشهر القليلة المقبلة،
ويقول مسؤول كبير في البيت الأبيض إن
فيروس كوفيد-19 من المرجح أن يكون له
التأثير الأكبر الذي لم نصل إليه مطلقًا، كما أن
حالات دخول المستشفى لم تصل إلى
الصفر أبدًا، ونحن نعيش الآن  هذا
العالم الذي نتظاهر فيه بأن مطمعنا
غير ذي صلة، من المتوقع أن يتم تحديث لقاح مطمع في
الشهر المقبل وتتوفر
بالفعل لقاحات الأنفلونزا والفيروس المخلوي التنفسي (RSV) إذا
نظرت إلى البلد ككل ونظرت
إلى خريطة البلد و
انظر إلى توصيات مركز السيطرة على الأمراض في معظم أنحاء
البلاد تعتبر منخفضة المخاطر، كما
تقول مراكز السيطرة على الأمراض والوقاية منها، بالإضافة إلى الحصول على
التطعيم، يجب على الأشخاص أيضًا تجربة
الاختبار المبكر لتحسين أنظمة التهوية
وفي بعض الحالات ارتداء الأقنعة بشكل
عام إذا لم تكن على ما يرام  إذا
كنت مريضًا، فإن أفضل ما يمكنك فعله هو
تجنب الاتصال بالأشخاص الآخرين إن
أمكن، وخاصة الأشخاص
المعرضين للخطر، أنا تقرير جون لورانس